vous allez avoir une interview cauchemar
on ne bouge pas pendant le génial
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien internes ou cauchemar
qu'elle pourrait être pour vous
salvatore adamo le pire des accidents
conjugaux vous faire surprendre par
votre femme quand vous êtes avec votre
maîtresse
surprendre votre femme avec votre
meilleure amie ou troisième solution
surprend
votre femme et votre maîtresse
oui je pense que ce serait su reprendre
ma femme dans les bras des meilleures
amies ouais ben oui ça serait le pire je
pensais qu est le pire cadeau qu'on
puisse vous faire une perceuse sans fil
un abonnement dans un club de gym ou le
nouveau cd d'un à rieux par exemple
aulas une perceuse sans fil
la pire situation au quotidien pour vous
c'est d'avoir une cigarette mais pas de
feu d'avoir une carte bleue mais pas de
code ou d'avoir une fille canon mais pas
de préservatif allez la dernière quand
même j'avertis ma femme que tout ça est
théorique n'est ce pas ouais ouais c'est
ce que voulait dit en rentrant
voici tu vas trouver ton meilleur ami à
dire que ces théories qui est alors à
une perceuse sans fil
quels correctifs pour vous la pire des
illusions apprendre qu'il ya quelqu'un
dans casimir
non thierry lafond mettait des
chaussettes dans son collant
que goldorak et doublé pour les cascades
awk chirac est mêlé à la sphère des hlm
de la ville de paris non je pense que
comme je crois encore au père noël
apprendre d'un coup qu'il ya quelqu'un
dans casimir ça roule vers ce serait ma
fille
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui est pire pour vous un
portable qui sonne tout le temps qui
sonne jamais
à qui sonne jamais ben
oui le pire c'est de grandir seul de
vivre seul ou de vieillir seul
je pense que c'est vieillir seul à avoir
connu la compagnie et puis se retrouver
seul parce que si on grandit seul on a
le temps de s'y habituer
il faut être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux